action by the way his first tv interview
since
departing the white house former energy
secretary rick perry
mr secretary governor good to see you
again uh
i hope you're enjoying a little bit of
retirement rest and relaxation but i
have a funny feeling knowing you you're
probably working hard
retirement's not on my uh not on my
radar sean
i believe that i believe that you know i
interviewed last night right here on
this program
guys that work in the pipeline and guys
that were talking about others
you know between the the interviews i've
been doing on radio and tv
these are career high paying
specialized trained jobs you're not
going to replace them
100 000 all the way up to 250 000
a year and just wiped out and now we'll
be dependent on energy again after
reaching energy independence in the
first time of 75 years
this is a disaster yeah
absolutely and you know one of one of
the things that caught my attention
when uh biden did this executive action
was john kerry uh piped in that
uh you know these people can go over and
get jobs
making solar panels well you know i
guess that's pretty easy
said for a guy that uh married into his
money
but uh these folks that have to really
work for their
their paychecks people who are out there
working really really hard to take care
of their families
uh for somebody just to say well won't
you just go over and work in some
other area well number one a lot of
those solar panels
are made in china and again
if you want to talk about who is the big
winner
out of these biden executive orders in
the energy sector
it's china it is um russia
it is iran it just flabbergasts me
to think that we've got a president of
the united states
that so wants to be liked by the aoc's
of the world or think that those
individuals with the green new deal are
somehow
going to keep him in office
and and to turn his back on
labor union workers people who are out
there
creating wealth and i might add
sean over the last uh
four years the emissions
because we were transitioning over to
natural
gas and getting these older inefficient
power plants
uh out of the out of the mix america was
doing its part
to move our emissions down and the
chinese
and i would suggest india as well or
over there
creating a huge amount of energy
using old inefficient and a lot of coal
power
uh coming out of of uh uh india and
china so
you know i i think we have to uh to
really look at
um what are we what are we doing here i
mean
what's the long term gains
for america and i'll suggest in the
energy sector in particular
there aren't any and let me just add
this one other thing
you know which state i think gets hurt
worse out of this
um out of this administration and these
executive orders
not only the the attack on fossil fuels
shutting down the excel pipeline
but this executive order to stop
drilling on federal lands
it's new mexico new mexico's democrat
governor
i mean i i'd love to have her on your
show to hear her
say what she's going to say about
their state's budget it's going to be
decimated
i mean my bet is it's probably over 50
percent and maybe even over 60 percent
of their total budget either the
director indirectly
that comes from the oil and gas industry
particularly
on those federal lands what would
governor grisham say if she was on this
program tonight about
joe biden's executive order on stopping
that drilling
on federal lands what would his nominee
for
department of interior a new mexican
citizen say about that you know it's
just sad that all of these things are
happening
now this is going to have a direct
impact on your state too
i feel terrible for all these people
that lost their job because we're not
going to replace them
highly skilled very specific
skill and we're we're endangering the
country
it's bad for national security we're all
going to pay more
and they're not going to replace it with
solar panels and win things you can't
translate that skill to that other
new business no matter how much money
they throw at it
secretary mr secretary i like the fact
you're welcome to come on a t-shirt at
any time shows you know
the rugged texas spirit which i love as
you know
hey listen um collard shirts are not
required in round top texas so uh this
is casual friday
um listen i'm all in if i can talk my
bosses into it i rip this stupid tie off
now but anyway thank you governor
uh let's appreciate it thanks for what
you're doing sean i think it's so
important for people to understand
how this administration is just gutting
uh americans middle-class americans who
really working hard for their uh
for their families they're just seeing
their jobs thrown away with the stroke
of a pen
new mexico is really going to be
impacted in an incredibly negative way
every american is going to be impacted
get ready
your heating bills went up and the price
you paid the pump is going way
up and they're not going to replace
those jobs just like
solyndra collapsed all right governor
thank you good to see you
uh